عدوه تسريح الموظفين تنتقل الى امازون
فبعد ان اعلنت متى ملكه فيسبوك وانستغرام
و واتساب في التاسعه من الشهر الحالي انها
ستسرح اكثر من 11 الف موظف وبعد الشراء
الى الماسك شركه التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر
وتسريحه 50% من موظفي الشركه تخطط امازون
عملاق التجاره الالكترونيه لتسريح نحو
عشره الاف شخصا في اكبر عمليه تسريح لها
منذ تاسيسها واقع يطرح الكثير من الاسئله
عن تداعيات هذه الاقالات على الموظفين
خاصه عندما تقوم بها كبريات الشركات التي
ما فاتت تعلن التزامها بتوفير الامان
والشفافيه لموظفيها بل ان بعض الخبراء
يؤكدون ان التداعيات السلبيه ستصيب
الشركات نفسها وهي التي اساءت التعامل مع
تسريح العاملين
الامم المتحده السامي لحقوق الانسان
والكرتون على سبيل المثال كن بعث رساله
الى ايلون ماسك يحثه فيها على ضمان ان
تكون حقوق الانسان امرا اساسيا بالنسبه
لاداره تويتر فيما نشرت مجله فورس
الامريكيه المختصه بالاعمال مقالا عن
مشاعر الغضب والخوف والقلق التي يشعر بها
الانسان عندما يفقد وظيفته وما يمكن ان
يقوم به لاداره هذا القلق وتقترح المجله
ما تسميه التشاؤم الدفاعي لمعالجه القلق
اي التدرب الذهنيه على الاستجابه لاسوء
السيناريوهات وهو ما يمكن ان يساعد المراه
في اداره القلق بطريقه صحيه في كل الاحوال
فان حاله من الفوضى وعدم اليقين قد سادت
بين الموظفين الذين تم تسريحهم من تويتر
وفيسبوك وامازون
الى السطح تساؤلات عما اذا كانت الطبيعه
الجماعيه للاقالات
مواساه للمقالين ام انها تحدي خطير لكل
فرد منهم وهو الذي سينشغل في البحث عن
فرصه العمل ذاتها التي سيتقدم لها الاف
المسرحين